breaking tonight major signs of progress
thank God in the fight against Kovan 19
the president's bold actions they are
working tonight and what the mob and the
media will never tell you is this the
Chinese European travel bans the
quarantine they saved this country your
fellow countrymen and women untold
amounts of suffering massive quantities
of federal supplies every state is
getting everything that they need in
record time thousands of ventilators
have been distributed and we have 10,000
still plus to spare if we need them god
forbid we do along with millions of n95
masks and millions more medical gowns
and gloves and all the other necessary
equipment every state in need and most
were not prepared they should have been
but they weren't the federal government
has helped at the highest level in a
medical mobilization that we have never
seen before in history and it has we can
report tonight thankfully been a success
on a lot of levels sure we can always
learn to do things better a massive
amount of federal aid has gone to new
york the epicenter of the disease
remember he sent the hospital ship the
comfort he ordered the Army Corps of
Engineers to build
numerous other emergency hospitals a
3,000 bed facility the largest in the
country
at the Javits Center and then they will
both turned into copa 19 patients where
they would take those incoming and both
those hospitals were staffed with
federal employees after being built by
the Army Corps of Engineers members of
the military stepping up as they always
do flawlessly over 20,000 hospital beds
built in less than a month and because
of the president's orders both the Navy
hospital the emergency hospital 3,000
beds that the Javits Center started to
accept Kovac 19 patients thankfully most
of those beds have not been needed and
now we are seeing signs of serious
improvement April 2nd the net change in
hospitalizations was up over 1400 but
during the weekend the cases dropped to
under a hundred and today there were
just a hundred and eighteen new cases
the numbers of critical care admissions
are even better the ICU patients
decreased by 40 to death in New York has
also declined
for the second day in a row and if
remember we kept saying if the patterns
hold you'll see a leveling off and then
a decline and then a precipitous decline
that will be the next step we hope even
Governor Andrew Cuomo admitting
president Trump played a significant
role in potentially flattening this
curve to save lives take a look
he has been good in delivering for New
York he is yes he is delivered for New
York the Army Corps of Engineers we
built thousands of beds he said the Navy
ship comfort to New York he has
delivered for New York yes and staffed
them and all the ventilators they didn't
buy he bought them in the state over
5,000 of them to start and despite what
you're now hearing from well some in the
media and some other people despite the
hopeful facts on the ground there is a
level of fear hysteria panic among many
on the left this frantic anxiety it
doesn't have to do anything with
coronavirus everything to do with how
well the administration has handled the
national crisis today during a powerful
press conference President Trump
rightfully tore them to shreds take a
look we did all of this work but when
you read the phony stories you know
buddy nobody acknowledges this and it
doesn't have to be acknowledged from my
standpoint but it does have to be
acknowledged from the great work that
these doctors nurses the Army Corps of
Engineers Fame all these people they've
done this incredible job and they
shouldn't be abused and I would love to
be able to say that we have a very
honest press honestly John there'd be
nothing I would be more proud of if the
press would work and I don't mind being
criticized but not when they're wrong
not when people have done a great job
President Trump was acting protecting
Americans from a future pandemic
Democrats obsessed with what they were
impeaching the president the mob and the
media cheering on their Democratic
colleagues every step of the way it is
clear the media mob is full of liars
they have smeared slandered besmirched
this president from the day he came down
that escalator at Trump Tower with
Melania Trump they are propaganda
outlets they are state-run
TV for the radical Democratic extreme
socialist party they spread endless lies
conspiracy theories one hoax one
conspiracy theory after another then
when they lie they never admit they're
wrong it is move on to the next set of
lies they are hateful this is a
destructive force for the country I've
been saying it now for three years they
have contempt for the American people
because they think they're smarter they
think they know better Donald Trump
success is their failure and by
extension if the president fails well
clearly that's what they want do they
care about the damage they're causing
the country apparently not and they
continue to cause damage it's clear they
have always wanted to defeat Donald
Trump 2016 what do they do they helped
Hillary as much as they could
ignoring her clear violation of the
Espionage Act
oh yeah the bleached bent and deleted
emails yeah they ignored her obstruction
of justice they ignored her unverifiable
now debunked dirty Russian dossier used
to spy on a candidate and later a
president they ignored the biggest abuse
of power corruption scandal in our
history
they advanced one lie after another lie
after another lie after a conspiracy
theory and lie and now they are ignoring
quid pro quo joe's misconduct and
covering for zero experience hunter the
whole Ukraine
oh we're against quid pro quos but not
Joe you're not getting the billion
unless you fire the prosecutor
investigating my zero experience son
that's getting paid millions it's clear
we understand they hate Donald Trump
they hate Trump supporters you like
Donald Trump they hate you they hate me
they hit a lot of us here on Fox they
hate Rush they hate Mark Levin they hate
others now the same bad actors that
brought you Russia Russia Russia Ukraine
Ukraine and Peach and Peach now they're
still lying to the American people once
again claiming that the president
somehow must be responsible for kovat 19
especially true of the New York Times
which has so much blind psychotic rage
they don't even fully comprehend forgive
them I guess they know not what they do
at this point in themselves we are now
breaking down some of their greatest
errors tonight for example that garbage
of a newspaper does pop
they hit peace quote he could have seen
what was coming behind Trump's failure
on the virus okay before the New York
Times tries to rewrite their history
let's remember China didn't publicly
identify we did not as a world know
about coronavirus until January 7th when
it first got a name the first case of
corona virus in the United States was
January 21st days later ten days later
after the first case January 31st the
president implemented the travel ban
then mandatory quarantines and then
subsequent travel bans declaring a
public health emergency
Trump haters everywhere they said he was
overreacting they said he was racist
Biden said he was acting out a
historical xenophobia and fear mongering
February 5th oh yeah that newspaper the
New York Times
their headline who says it's not safe to
travel to China
well great advice for your readers
adding that the coronavirus travel ban
is unjust it doesn't work anyway well it
worked at this time even the country's
top specialists weren't predicting a
widespread national crisis now for
example there is no better more renowned
more respected doctor on the issue of
pandemic a man that has spent his entire
life saving lives coming up with
treatment dr. Anthony pouchy the
country's leading infectious disease
expert he has dedicated his life to
fighting infectious diseases and saving
lives he has served under six US
presidents this is his life calling in
his lifework
perhaps no one in the world knows more
about infectious diseases than doctor
pouchy what I'm about to show you this
is not an attack on dr. pouchy number
one China lied to the world number two
this is about context start on January
20th at the time dr. pouchy he wasn't
sure the disease would spread from
person to person by the way nobody knew
January 21st found she said kovat 19 was
not a major threat to the people the US
the 2030 said that there's no chance in
the world that the u.s. could shut down
a major city like New York or San
Francisco the twenty-sixth theory
emphasized coronavirus isn't something
americans need to worry about January 30
the day the president enacted the travel
ban while he said we still have a low
risk to the American people February
17th he called the risk mutant minuscule
as late as March 9th doctor foul she
said healthy Americans generally healthy
you can go on a cruise ship if you're
healthy not an attack on dr. pouchy he
was making determinations based on facts
as they were unfolding in real time
doing his best as everyone else was but
it does shed a bright light on the
president's decision early on to be
called racist xenophobic fear monger or
etc to put the travel ban into effect in
fact his doctor pouchy clarified today
President Trump used doctor foul cheese
expertise and dr. Burks is expertise
expertise too as to important tools to
make critical decisions every single
step of the way they corroborated they
work together in the interest of the
American people was it perfect science
nope these things never are are they
take a look the first and only time that
dr. Burks and I went in and formally
made a recommendation to the president
to actually have a quote shut down in
the sense of not really shut down but to
really have strong mitigation we
discussed it obviously they would be
concerned by some that in fact that
might have some negative consequences
nonetheless the president listened to
the recommendation and went to the
mitigation the president relied on the
experts but even in spite of it nobody
really thought the travel ban was needed
at that time and he was widely
criticized and his own observations
about what was happening in China his
own gut instinct the President had the
foresight the courage the wisdom to do
something no other president has done
had at a quarantine in over 50 years in
this country the travel ban quarantined
public-private partnerships rewriting
all the books on how we deal with
pandemics right before our eyes we are
witnessing witnessing a paradigm shift
it is saving untold
American lives it is prevented untold
tens of thousands of other Americans
from contracting the disease
extrapolating out from their saving
American lives the media mob they
continue to lie there now look nobody's
doubt it there's still important work to
be done we've got to stay focused on not
only beating the disease but also
figuring out a way to reopen the economy
we can't go on like this forever
not enough money you can't print it your
way out of this mess now this will be
especially tricky in those high-density
population areas for example it's going
to be a lot more challenging in New York
City than any other place my position
okay if half the workforce if you have
for example essential non-essential
personnel many Americans it will be a
new normal now for people to work from
home in numbers never before seed people
going in to work they might have the
temperature taken they might even have
to get a coven 19 test a social
distancing will be a part of less
crowded office space all of that gloves
masks for the time being there is a
disruption in everybody's life now keep
in mind our economy it never fully
closed truckers were working farmers
were working grocers were working
manufacturers of medical equipment and
ventilators they were all working harder
to keep the country safe
to take care of our first responders and
hospitals all across the country their
safety their well-being so critically
important but so too are our inalienable
rights as we go towards reopening
business in the country we can't deny
civil liberties constitutional rights
people have a right to medical privacy
you can't be tracking Americans as they
travel we can't have nationwide
databases with America's personal health
information on it I don't trust any of
them in Washington and the swamp the
constitutional infringement coming from
some state local governments this has to
stop in Greensville Mississippi for
example people ticketed $500 for
attending a drive-through church service
drive-through socially distant church
service one California town issuing an
order mandating residents where mass
where when
they leave their homes we have one guy
in Pennsylvania ripped off a bus because
he'd have a mask on by ten cops
Michigan's governor banning all
gatherings of any size including
residents owned homes also banning the
purchase of seeds and plants and certain
types of fishing why governor huckabee
rightly stating that's where that would
shred the Constitution